touché mais pas coulé au mondial la
france concède le match nul 0 0 face à
l'uruguay mais retrouve son niveau de
jeu tout reste possible pour la
qualification
tennis plus de français à roland garros
sébastien grosjean a été sorti par le
russe safin les espagnols ferrero et
corps et déjà sont également qualifiés
pour le dernier carré
chez les dames finale en famille entre
les deux soeurs williams première
confrontation à evreux dans l' enquête
sur la mort d'un père de famille qui
défend des son fils la justice cherche à
éclaircir certains points obscurs un
témoignage ce soir celui précisément du
fils de la victime
faut-il autoriser l'adoption des enfants
par des couples homosexuels le conseil
d'état a tranché c'est non au même
moment la suède donne son feu vert
adieu lustucru la célèbre marque est
racheté par son concurrent panzani
les salariés s'inquiètent pour leur sort
et réclame aussi une prime de rachat ils
sont en grève depuis près d'un mois
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
d'abord un rendez vous à trois jours du
premier tour des législatives jean
pierre chevènement et françois bayrou
sont les invités d'élections 2002 avec
olivier mazerolle et gérard leclerc
juste après ce journal le mondial donc
la france a été tenu en échec par
l'uruguay 0 0 pour son deuxième match un
match attendu rugueux mais de qualité
les bleus réduits à 10 peuvent
préserve pardon leurs chances de
qualification christophe du scion dans
la série les coûts et les couleurs l
arbitre mexicain monsieur ramos a fait
carton plein entre le rouge et le jaune
chacun a eu son compte mais ça n'est pas
pour ça que le compte est bon
à thierry henry le rouge après 25
minutes de jeu pour ce tacle viril et
pas très correct expulsé pour jeu
dangereux
admettons mais alors pourquoi l'arbitré
voit-il jaune et non pas rouge sur cette
action coupable de l'exciter dario silva
pourquoi ne s'y peut-il rien quand
trezeguet balayée en pleine surface de
réparation
bref entre la france l'uruguay et le peu
diplomate monsieur ramos on a souvent
frôlé la rupture des relations
footballistiques en juin dix pendant
plus d'une heure en perdant le boeuf sur
blessure la france a frôlé la
catastrophe
et parfois le grand bonheur comme sur ce
coup franc de petits qui touche le
poteau
comme sur ce tir à bout portant de
trezeguet brillamment détournée par le
gardien uruguayen
comme sur cette action de deals tordent
contrer au tout dernier moment
avec un peu de réussite et d'efficacité
ce match la france aurait pu le gagner
remarquez bien pour être honnête la
france aurait pu perdre et la suite été
l'élimination
le retour à la maison mère au terminus
des prétentieux
quand ça n'est pas barthès qui
s'interposaient c'est recoba et ses
copains qui gâchait la marchandise alors
que leur part marcel car ce zéro à zéro
c'est plus qu'un match nul
non seulement la france n'a pas perdu
mais en plus elle a gagné oui elle a
gagné le droit de rêver encore un peu et
c'est le premier 0 0 en 20 matches dans
ce mondial
il laisse donc aux français une
impression mélangé de frustration et de
soulagement aussi envoyés spéciaux en
corée du sud florent gautreau andré
jammes les bleus n'ont pas gagné mais
ils n'ont pas perdu leurs supporters
massés à l'extérieur de l'hôtel et dans
le hall ils ont accueilli les joueurs
chaleureusement
c'est donc dans la difficulté a dit ce
qu'on pense que l'équipe de france s'est
réconcilié avec son public qui lui
pardonne donc tout à 10 je pense qu'ils
ont fait un bon match ils ont sorti les
tripes et s'ils font comme ça contre le
danemark je pense qu'il devrait pas y
aura de problème pour gagner déjà la
révolte
c'est un con si parce que maintenant il
faut les laisser faire leur faire
confiance pour que peu de chances qu'il
soit le défi sera difficile mais il y
avait ce soir dans les regards une lueur
que l'on avait perdu ces dernières
semaines une volonté commune qui
rappelait la bande à jacquet il faudra
toutefois se passer de thierry henry et
compter sur le retour de zidane
si l'équipe de france n'a pas trouvé la
faille dans la rugueuse défense
uruguayenne elle a en revanche retrouvé
un état d'esprit solidarité cohésion sur
le terrain et aussi en dehors puisque
les joueurs et leurs épouses ont tous
mangé ensemble après le match dans leur
hôtel au programme demain du repos et le
décrassage bien sûr toujours abuse and
l'équipe de france ne retrouvera à son
camp de base à séoul que samedi matin
soit trois jours avant france danemark
oui emmanuel petit qui a écopé d'un
deuxième carton jaune risque d'être
suspendu lui aussi en france pendant
près de deux heures une bonne partie du
pays s'est arrêté
ambiance dans les usines sur les places
publiques ou dans les endroits à la mode
même nervosité même enthousiasme images
et témoignages recueillis par l'ensemble
de nos équipes est rassemblée par david
beaudry dernière soudure
il est bientôt 13h30 l'atelier se vide
et tout s'arrête c'est chaudronnier gare
de leur bleu de travail comme panoplie
de supporters s'est dit on va quand même
garder nos nos habits qui nous
caractérise tous les jours pour soutenir
les bleus
tout se passe ici dans cette salle de
réunion les salariés peuvent suivre
l'équipe de france sur un écran géant
près de deux heures de coupure qui
seront rattrapés plus tard dans la
journée
au premier rang le directeur est un
supporters ça fait partie des d élément
mobilisateur au rassembleur et ça vaut
le coup de dirt de tourner ça en
activité un peu plus convivial quoi pour
le progrès
une après midi conviviale mais surtout
très intense à lyon chez cet éditeur de
jeux vidéo qui salariés sont beaucoup
plus confortablement installés ils ont
eux aussi quitté leur poste de travail
pour suivre les exploits des bleus c'est
une chanson là parce que c'est pas très
gentil
christine le projet
à nous nous organiser en fait par notre
travail de toute façon il ils auraient
regardé d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc effectivement c'est mieux qu'ils
soient là et qu'ils soient tous ensemble
à paris entre midi et deux sur les
trottoirs les places sont chères les
vitrines de magasin vidéo sont prises
d'assaut
certains sont prêts à avaler un casse
croûte en pleine rue contre quelques
minutes de match pas j'ai du bol parce
que je suis avec mon patron est donc une
couvre mais normalement je bosse la plus
inconfortable mais
rendre au tour de yogo et même pour ceux
qui travaillent toutes les occasions
sont bonnes du numéro comme d'habitude
dans le pari est embouteillée mais là ça
nous arrange dans ce bar bordelais ils
les ont soutenus jusqu'au bout et en
grand connaisseur du ballon rond les
supporters déçus le retrouve toutes les
meilleures excuses
salah sur la mi temps franchement ils
font ce qu'ils dispensent qui viendra
faire quoi ils commis il ya un arbitrage
qui est pas bon il ya une solution juste
et le score à la mi-temps à marseille
dans le quartier de la castellane ces
jeunes ont suivi le match est pour eux
la contre performance des bleus
s'explique pas gagné t'inquiète pas ce
gars n'est pas l'équipe de france n'a
toujours pas remporté de victoire
pourtant partout en france comme ici sur
la place de l'hôtel de ville à paris les
supporteurs étaient prêts à laisser tes
comme à la belle époque on repart le
sport est arithmétique car la france a
donc encore son destin entre les mains
pour se qualifier avec certitude pour
les huitièmes de finale il lui faut
battre le danemark avec au moins deux
buts d'écart c'est à sa portée le
danemark qui a fait match nul avec le
sénégal un partout aujourd'hui je manuel
tissier ce penalty de thomason aurait pu
envoyer le danemark en huitièmes de
finale
mais l'égalisation sénégalaise de dia ho
laisse le suspense entier dans ce groupe
à le danemark et le sénégal sont en tête
avec 4 points et une différence de buts
positive avec zéro but marqué un point
la france est dernière
tout va se jouer mardi prochain dans la
dernière rencontre
la france affronte le danemark comme en
1998 les bleus sont éliminés en cas de
défaite ou de match nul
même une victoire 1-0 2-1 les condamnent
la différence de buts resterait alors
défavorable aux champions du monde
mais la france maîtrisent encore son
avenir dans la compétition
une victoire avec deux buts d'écart
l'enverrait à coup sûr en huitième de
finale il existe d'autres hypothèses
souriante mais elles dépendent aussi du
match uruguay sénégal le même jour à la
même heure à l'euro 2000 la france avait
battu le danemark 3 0 un score idéal
pour raviver les souvenirs et redonner
l'espoir
oui lors des trois dernières rencontres
les français en a chaque fois battu les
danois de plus et au rhic mans mardi
prochain zinédine zidane devrait être
sur la pelouse c'est ce qu'a indiqué le
défenseur français vincent candela
l'autre match du jour
il opposait le cameroun à l'arabie
saoudite victoire 1-0 pour le cameroun
eu des taux à la 65e minute
les saoudiens sont donc les premiers
éliminés de cette coupe du monde deux
défaites le tennis maintenant sébastien
grosjean lui n'a pas le droit à une
nouvelle chance il a été éliminé
sèchement par le russe marat safin tête
de série numéro 2 autre battu du jour
andre agassi nathanaël de rincquesen
nadine picard ces jours ci les sportifs
français ont quelques problèmes avec
leurs cuisses après zidane
voilà grosjean qui tire la pâte à roland
garros en quarts de finale face à marat
safin
ça ne pardonne pas d'autant que cet
après midi le russe était dans un bon
jour
6 3 6 2 6 2 l'affairé est entendue en
1h43 il n'y a plus de français à roland
garros
ça n'enlève rien à la qualité du jeu de
marathon aujourd'hui je crois que je
suis un petit peu diminué mais lui a
fait son match
andrée galzy a lui aussi tiré sa
révérence
la faute à juan carlos ferrero un des
trois espagnols encore qualifié ferrero
s'est imposé en quatre sets et
retrouvera sa fine demain en demi finale
maman et papa williams son sourire il ya
de quoi
serena a éliminé en trois manches
jennifer capriati la numéro un mondiale
et samedi en finale elle retrouvera
venus sa grande soeur et oui venise bill
williams qui a battu l'argentine
clarissa fernandez 6 1 6 4 une finale
donc en famille
la qualité en france vous le voyez c'est
ce soir encore l' enquête sur la sphère
d'evreux nous vous indiquions récemment
que le dossier n'était peut-être pas
aussi simple qu'on l'avait dit à savoir
un père de famille battu à mort alors
qu'il défendrait son fils racketter par
une bande et y at il vraiment eu
raquette qui était armé c'est pour y
voir plus clair qu'une confrontation
était organisée aujourd'hui et nous
avons pu à cette occasion recueillir un
témoignage central celui précisément du
fils de la victime paul de genève
régis mater trois mois après la mort de
son père patrice jbeil accepte de nous
parler il était à côté de lui ce soir là
au pôle des changes d'evreux mon père
était là bas et mon cas mon frère
mais moi je suis arrivé en en marchant
et v fadila d'après l'arrêt de bus avec
tous ses copains et dès que j'arrive un
marchand en fait j'étais au niveau de
l'ue dernier camion là bas et dès que
j'arrivais ils ont tous arrivés en
courant vers moi mon père ici oui comme
ça tout de s'arrêter là dieu ouais il
hier soir mon fils a commencé à wayne il
s'est fait agresser il va savoir
pourquoi a pris cette fois je vais à
comprendre ils ont tapé la bagarre
éclate
mais que s'est il passé avant que
patrice bug ne reçoivent une brique en
pleine tête avait t'il un cutter à la
main il n'est pas que ta main parce que
il dit ça parce qu'il ya une chose de
cartes qu'il y avait un cutter soussou
son banc je sais pourquoi mais qu'est ce
qui prouve que ça monte pas au cutter il
y avait tellement ici sable est tombé
par terre et est à quelqu'un qui est
parti en courant
là on n'a pas été retrouvée par la
police pour tant d'autres témoins
parlent également de ce tuteur est
principalement c'est justement ecfa dit
que jimmy s'est battu la veille pour une
histoire de fille d'adolescents
aujourd'hui tous deux se sont retrouvés
devant le juge pour une première
confrontation
au vu de ces éléments l'avocat de fady
doit demander sa libération
dès demain je vais présenter une demande
de mise en liberté
et deuxième chose c'est que je vais
demander à ce qu'il y ait une
reconstitution
ça m'apparaît d'un élément déterminant
au stade actuel de l'action ce soir à la
sortie du tribunal
timmy se dit satisfait personne dit mon
père les a agressés ont dit que se monte
à s'est défendu et sais me défendre donc
ça déjà c'est beaucoup pour moi selon
nos informations les deux adolescents
incarcéré présents aujourd'hui ni avoir
jeté la brique la confrontation n'a pas
apporté toutes les réponses que se
posent encore la justice autre affaire
qui provoque beaucoup d'interrogations
le meurtre de cette lycéenne inspirée
semble-t-il par le film scream
on en sait un peu plus sur la
personnalité de l'adolescent sans
histoires apparemment qui a porté les
coups de couteau son acte était
prémédité
programmée depuis un an d'après son
avocate qui indique aussi qu'il aurait
très mal vécu l'annoncé de son
redoublement
orolia guillemin josé boulesteix chaque
jour ils sont plus nombreux à venir se
recueillir ici à l'endroit même où alice
15 ans a reçu plusieurs dizaines de
coups de couteau défaits désormais
précisément décrits par leurs auteurs
julien entendu hier pendant plus d'une
heure et demie n'a rien nier de son
geste il n'avait pas l'intention de tuer
la liste son attention et quête de ce
sont les premiers mots d'ailleurs qu'ils
ont frappé lorsque je les ai entendus
dans la première heure de garde à vue de
voir comment cela s'est il poignarder
son pensé à aucun moment je pense sans
réaliser à aucun moment que un coup deux
coups 45 ou et puis tu vas tu analystes
décrit par tous comme un garçon modèle
julien raconte aujourd'hui qu'il
échafauder des plans criminels depuis
bientôt un an
un profond malaise révélé par le passage
à l'acte
il dit que sa vie était quelque chose de
transparent était quelque chose de
monocorde en tout cas d'inintéressant il
s'est qualifiée de fantôme
j'étais un bon copain pour tout le monde
ce terme qu'on fera jeter un bon fils
mais sans plus mise en examen pour
assassinat
julien a été écroué à la maison d'arrêt
de nantes il risque la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
à propos de crimes à suivre ce soir une
enquête d'envoyé spécial sur le plus
ordinaire des crimes on sait peu mais
plus de la moitié des homicides commis
en france le sont dans le cadre conjugal
et huit fois sur dix c'est l'homme le
meurtrier en général par refus de la
séparation envoyé spécial à 21h05
en bref les violences à sangatte au
centre de la croix rouge un homme a été
tué par balle lors d'une nouvelle rixe
entre demandeurs d'asile il s'agit d'un
passeur kurde et irakien
dix hommes ont été interpellés la nuit
dernière ils sont toujours ce soir en
garde à vue le débat sur l'adoption des
enfants par les couples homosexuels et
cette décision très attendue le conseil
d'état confirme sa jurisprudence
il a rejeté le pourvoi d'une
institutrice de 39 ans qui souhaitait
adopter avec sa compagne en première
instance les garanties avaient été
jugées insuffisantes sur les plans
familial éducatif et psychologique
l'adoption n'est pas la seule réponse au
désir d'enfant dans ces cas là chaque
année de nombreux couples de femmes
homosexuelles se rendent en belgique
pour une insémination artificielle qui
est interdit en france
voici l'exemple d'un de ces couples nous
l'avons suivi lors de son voyage à
bruxelles
reportage et les honneurs guère réagi ce
matin elles ont failli rater leur train
pourtant ce voyage en belgique
elle y pense depuis trois ans christiane
et muriel 18 ans de vie commune et l'
envie d'un bébé seront à liège dans deux
heures l'enfant qu'elle élèveront
ensemble c'est muriel qui le portera
beaucoup de questions c'est beaucoup
d'obstacles à surmonter quoi lui dire
est ce qu'on doit tout vous dire est ce
qu'on doit le cacher des choses
qu'est-ce qu'ils se les questions de
gordes pratique quand il sera l'école
comment comment il sera perçu par ses
copains si la silla deux mamans au lieu
d'avoir un moment une pape est un papa
ce qu'on a le droit de le priver de bava
il ya cette question là aussi pour elle
la loi belge est une aubaine ici elles
peuvent recourir à l'insémination
artificielle
une méthode qui leur est interdite en
france c'est leur premier rendez vous à
l'hôpital de la citadelle en est besoin
avant d'envisager une première
insémination christiane et muriel
doivent convaincre l'équipe médicale du
sérieux de leurs projets pour les
couples homosexuels
ces procédures est obligatoire comment
vous allez pouvoir l'aider
quelque part supporter le poids du
regard de la société c'est peut-être
effectivement pour d'évolution ce qui me
frappe peut-être dans les demandes
actuelles c'est qu'en général elles sont
beaucoup plus réfléchie qu'elle ne
l'était il ya quelques quelques années
peut-être moins une militante été témoin
dans quelques minutes
rendez vous avec la psychologue s'est
toujours dit que qui saurait la vérité
sur son origine assure son sur sa
conception un moment décisif
mais ce n'est pas pendant l'entretien
qui nourrit les chrétiens trouveront des
réponses comment est question pas par
essence
pourquoi retour à paris ici famille et
amis soutiennent les deux femmes pour le
frère et la belle-soeur de christiane le
rôle de l'entourage sera même essentiel
dans l'éducation de l'enfant enfants
besoin d'un père et d'une mère tel que
le sont les schémas habituels à suivre
c'est un petit peu hors du commun mais à
partir du moment où il va être entouré
puis puis mais moi je pense que ce dont
il sera entouré
ça c'est sûr apparemment il y aura pas
de problème date c'est bientôt
christiane et muriel recevront la vie de
l'hôpital à la clé peut-être un nouveau
voyage en belgique cette fois pour une
première insémination alors coïncidence
de dates aujourd'hui et après des débats
animés la suède vient de voter le droit
à l'adoption pour les couples
homosexuels c'est le deuxième pays en
europe après le pays bas à prendre une
telle disposition
le débat sur le smic de combien faut-il
augmenter au 1er juillet prochain le ps
promet en cas de victoire une hausse de
5% à droite françois bayrou demande
aussi un coup de pouce substantielle le
ministre de l'économie lui souhaite se
limiter à la hausse légale calculées à
partir de l'inflation sans plus
décision dans l'intérêt des entreprises
et par conséquent des travailleurs
indique francis mer économie toujours
avec la bataille des pâtes panzani
rachète lustucru la fin d'un monde
l'opération provoque l'inquiétude des
salariés qui réclament aussi leur part
du gâteau
si l'on peut dire martin gwen daniel
lainé seuls les grévistes peuvent
franchir ses grilles
depuis que lustucru est à vendre l'usiné
de marseille est bloqué les 123 salariés
du site veulent eux aussi profiter de la
transaction on veut notre part du gâteau
pour accompagner les pâtes à l'eau c'est
pas fini non non c'est pas fini mais si
on peut les accompagner
c'est bien le gâteau ce sont les 500
millions d'euros plus rapportera cette
vente une prime de risque pour les
salariés dont certains sont là depuis 35
ans et qui ont peur pour leur avenir en
devenir c'est du vieux mais notre
travail vous avez à partir de 40
quelques années on est vieux normalement
ce sont 600 tonnes de pâte qui sortent
d'ici toutes les semaines
aujourd'hui 8000 palettes sont bloqués
les salariés craignent également la
disparition d'une des marques les plus
emblématiques de la cuisine française
quand il va le marché sûr qu'on a peur
de voir disparaître ce cru des salariés
qui ne donnent pas leur bénédiction au
rapprochement avec tanzanie ce ne sont
que des pâtes
monseigneur banza ni rachèterait en
effet les pâtes fraîches de lustucru
mais les deux marques pourraient
continuer à vivre l'une à côté de
l'autre
l'enjeu important des marques c'est la
présence dans les points de vente dans
les supermarchés dans les hypermarchés
donc le fait d'avoir plusieurs marques
permet aux fabricants qui gère plusieurs
marques d'avoir plus d'espacés consacrés
à leurs marques et les pâtes sèches
produite à marseille tomberez quant à
elle dans l'assiette du numéro 2 italien
la fin d'une histoire qui a un arrière
goût pour les marseillais
les chiffres du bac rendu public
aujourd'hui
628 1875 candidats cette année une
légère baisse -0 4% par rapport à 2001
dans le détail on s'aperçoit qu'un peu
plus de la moitié vont passer le bac
général 52 % exactement 23 % le bac
technologique et dix huit et demi pour
cent le bac professionnel première
épreuve la philo le 13 juin est à noter
qu'à l'occasion de la présentation de
ces chiffres le ministre délégué à
l'enseignement scolaire xavier darcos a
indiqué que l'objectif de 80% d'une
classe d'âge au niveau bac était
abandonné il n'est pas réaliste à nos
yeux dit-il c'est une illusion
le chiffre actuel est d'environ 60%
santé le congrès mondial de la maladie
coeliaque vient de s'achever à paris ce
nom ne vous dit sans doute rien mais
elle touche 150 mille personnes en
france
il s'agit d'une intolérance au gluten
petite protéine qui se trouve dans la
farine le pain les viennoiseries les
pattes
d'où des contraintes très importante
dans la vie quotidienne
jean daniel flaysakier christophe pignol
demandé à valérie ce qui l'attend dans
ce rayon boulangerie elle vous dira
demandez lui ce qu'elle peut manger elle
vous répondra rien valérie et
intolérantes au gluten le gluten est une
protéine qu'on trouve dans le blé l'orge
le seigle le froment
si d'aventuré valérie se laisser aller à
consommer un des produits de ce rayon
son organisme réagir est très violemment
on va très clairement c'est faux
dégraissant la fatigue c'est ainsi qu'on
a découvert sa maladie il ya trois ans
quand elle a perdu brutalement cinq
kilos depuis donc elle se livre à la
chasse au gluten il faut passer beaucoup
de temps à lire les étiquettes et
valérie doit faire ses courses en deux
fois une grande partie de ces achats se
fait dans des magasins de diététique
comme celui ci elle petit trouver par
exemple un pain de campagne un peu
particulier c'est fait avec le du maïs
du riz est très souvent du sarrasin ça
remplace le pain c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose et c'est meilleure grille
et bien entendu pas ce que c'est
sinon un petit peu et tout chrétien va
tenir ces pratiques mais très cher 4
euros les cinq tranches de pain c'est à
dire un peu plus de 5 francs la tranche
alors rentrer chez elle valérie l'école
soigneusement les étiquettes des
produits et les envoie à sa caisse de
sécurité sociale
c'est le médecin qui demande une prise
en charge à la sécurité sociale
et avec cette ordonnance nous permet de
se faire rembourser les une partie des
produits ce qu'une partie effectivement
qui reste à la charge du consommateur
venez me l'expliquer des eaux qui
perdent leur calcium ceux d'une femme
jeune doit faire penser à l'intolérance
au gluten
cent cinquante mille personnes en
souffrent en france beaucoup l'ignorent
encore l'actualité à l'étranger la
réplique israélienne aux attentats
d'hier d'abord raid de l'armée
ramallah où les appartements privés de
yasser arafat ont été pris pour cible
dorothée olliéric durant le raid
israélien qui a duré six heures le qg de
yasser arafat a été à nouveau gravement
de magie des dégâts jusque dans la
chambre du leader palestinien
un garde du corps de yasser arafat a été
tué ainsi que sept autres palestiniens
pour les israéliens
c'était une riposte à l'attentât d'hier
qui leur est bien sûr encore à la colère
mais dit il personne ne vaincra le
peuple palestinien
le ministre de l'information a lui
estimé que ce raid israélien fourni
c'est une nouvelle caisse de la guerre
totale livrée par israël à l'autorité
palestinienne
ce matin yasser arafat est sorti sous
les applaudissements
l'armée israélienne s'est retirée après
ce raid provisoirement décollage réussi
pour la navette spatiale endeavour à cap
canaveral en floride ce matin très tôt à
son bord sept astronautes dont le
français philippe perrin mission de 13
jours consacrée à l'assemblage de la
station spatiale internationale et à la
relève
je vous trouve à l'expédition 4 à bord
de l' iss depuis plus de six mois
à propos des espaces à noter pour la
première fois l'adoption d'une loi
contre ce qu on appelle ces nouveaux la
pollution lumineuse l'as passe en
république tchèque
mais de fait les astronomes et certains
écologistes réclament depuis longtemps
que la nuit soit classée patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité
reportage explications sophie mais elle
guillaume viard ce serait un chasseur de
trésors que sa quête ne serait pas plus
illusoire
sept hommes recherchent désespérément
une vraie nuit noire donc là même en
s'enfonçant au fond du jardin
je récupère de nouveaux lampadaires donc
en fait tous les points du jardin sont
facturées alors dès que la nuit tombe il
parcourt une dizaine de kilomètres pour
atterrir là en plein milieu d'un champ
de blé que l'on ne verra pas et pour
cause
ici au moins il fait noir le ciel va
enfin pouvoir livrer ses étoiles membres
de l'association pour la défense de la
nuit nocturne
cet astronome amateur combat ce qu'il
appelle la pollution lumineuse sur un
plan culturel et sociologique ça prive
les hommes de la vision du ciel étoilé
et sur un plan plus environnementalistes
ça a un impact sur les espèces nocturnes
et de fait les espèces animales habitués
à se déplacer de nuit sont perturbées
par la lumière électrique
cette lumière omniprésente qui noms des
villes et les campagnes lumière
rassurante sécurisante mais aussi
synonyme de richesse ostentatoire
la démonstration est flagrante sur cette
planisphère chaque point est
photographié au beau milieu de la nuit
l'hémisphère nord brille de mille feux
quand l'hémisphère sud et dans
l'obscurité presque absolu les
scientifiques estiment qu'aujourd'hui
les deux tiers de l'humanité sont privés
de véritables nuit un citoyen du monde
sur deux ne serait plus en mesure
d'observer la voie lactée
un mot des intempéries en france avec
des orages toujours très violent dans
certaines régions des trombes d'eau se
sont par exemple a battu il ya moins de
trois heures près de voiron dans l'isère
une voiture a même été emportés par une
coulée de boue mais il n'y a pas de
victimes plusieurs rivières ont débordé
les routes départementales sont coupées
on signale aussi des inondations un peu
plus au sud dans la drôme
après des pluies diluviennes du côté de
saint jean en royans et des communes
alentour images d'italie aussi
touchés ces orages les régions du nord
notamment le val d'aoste le piémont la
lombardie la vénétie orage très violent
en signal de nombreuses maisons inondées
certaines ont dû être évacuées
des routes sont coupées en s'attend à de
nouvelles précipitations la nuit
prochaine
toutes les précisions dans un instant
avec nathalie rihouet sur ce qui nous
attend du côté du ciel dans les heures
qui viennent
les derniers meetings de la campagne des
législatives jean pierre raffarin et ce
soir 1 marseille en compagnie de nicolas
sarkozy présent également à ses côtés
jean claude gaudin bien sûr le maire de
la ville dont on court le dernier grand
meeting de l'ump qui commence à peine
françois hollande lui est en déplacement
dans la région lyonnaise étape à saint
priest à bron où jean jacques queyranne
est opposé à charles millon mais c'est à
villeurbanne ici
que se déroulera ce soir le dernier
meeting du premier secrétaire du ps avec
les élus du département
la circonscription du jour celle de
martine aubry on prédit à la maire de
lille
une bataille très difficile emilie
lançons thierry breton on va flinguer là
parce que c'est inacceptable ce qui
viens de faire la chose à droite
sébastien huyghe se rongent les sangs
il vient d'être investi par l'union pour
la majorité présidentielle mais pas de
chance ses adversaires de droite se
revendique de la même majorité de maires
de communes de la circonscription ont
été vexés
quand il fait confiance plutôt un jeune
pour des cours pour défendre les comment
les couleurs de l'ump et ils sont allés
quand même à l'élection jusqu'au dernier
moment ils ont hésité pour savoir lequel
serait le suppléant de l'autre ils ont
pas en revanche toujours été d'accord
pour dire que la majorité présidentielle
c'est aussi eux
mais bon chirac on est pro de majorité
présidentielle on est pour donner un
sens à notre pays une action dans une
seule voie un président et un
gouvernement de droite à l'extrême
droite aussi c'est compliqué front
national et à mes nerfs vont s'affronter
mais le candidat du mnr était celui du
fn il ya cinq ans ça c'est ma vieille
affiche de 97g ans mais la flamme j'en
fais le bandeau front national et puis
ça me fait une belle affiche pour
débuter la campagne puis quand les
nouvelles arrivantes
les choses sont claires martine aubry
tout le monde la connaît on veut même se
faire photographier avec elle
mais la partie s'annonce serrée alors le
maire de lille justifie les réunions car
chaque voix compte quoi qu'il arrive et
comme je l'avais dit à lionel jospin
je souhaite rester ici parce que je
crois que les gens du nord ont besoin
qu'on se batte pour eux et que moi j'ai
envie de le faire dans ma ville comme
ici dans ma circonscription
dans ce bastion gauche personne ne sait
quel sera le résultat dimanche et encore
moins à quoi ressemblera le deuxième
tour les enjeux de ces législatives
d'abord on va découvrir la liste
complète des candidats de cette
circonscription du nord conformément à
la loi ou et cette liste est ce que nous
l'avons la voici
voici donc l'ensemble des candidats je
vous laisse les découvrir et on
s'intéresse maintenant comme chaque soir
à l'enjeu de ces législatives les enjeux
et ce soir la fiscalité qu'elles
baissent ou quelles hausses d'impôts
pour qui et pour quoi faire les
programmes des uns et des autres très
vite un des agents louis poussèrent sur
le diagnostic calcul fait et refait tout
le monde est d'accord la pression
fiscale qui pèse sur les ménages
français est trop forte
mais pour les remèdes c'est différent il
y à bien la matière un programme de
gauche et un programme de droite 1
pour l'ump le plus urgent c'est de
s'attaquer à l'impôt sur le revenu payé
par 15 millions de français
en cinq ans il serait réduit d'un tiers
et dès cette année de 5% dans tous les
pays du monde
l'impôt sur le revenu pèse moins
lourdement qu'il ne pens
oui ou non est ce que nous avons raison
contre le monde entier est ce que nous
allons enfin nous évader des vieux
clichés des vieilles formules toutes
faites notre objectif c'est de relancer
la croissance et d'emploi c'est ça la
juste
la droite propose encore la baisse de la
tva dans l'hôtellerie et la restauration
et enfin une charte du contribuable
donnant à celui-ci de nouveaux droits
devant le fisc au parti socialiste c'est
un autre impôt qui est jugé prioritaire
la taxe d'habitation
elles seraient réduites de moitié en
moins députés on vient me voir en me
disant monsieur le député je peux pas
payer mes impôts c'est pas de l'impôt
sur le revenu qu'on parle c'est toujours
de la taxe d'habitation et surtout comme
ça touchera les plus modestes sera
beaucoup plus d'effet sur la relance en
matière économique car les plus riches
sur diminue leur impôt sur le revenu y
vont épargner vont pas consommer plus
baisse de la tva dans les restaurants le
ps est également pour mais avec des
hausses de salaire à la clé
il propose enfin de prélever l'impôt à
la source c'est-à-dire au moment où le
revenu est perçue bref à droite comme à
gauche c'est l'heure des additions et
des soustractions bien entendu cela
coûte plusieurs milliards d'anciens
francs
aujourd'hui on parle en euros mais en
matière d'impôts on continue les savants
calculs
la politique toujours sur france 2 tout
une élection 2002 jean-pierre
chevènement et françois bayrou
ensuite la météo nathalie rihouet point
route valérie maurice 21h05 envoyé
spécial avec donc un portage sur les
crimes passionnels 00h50 dernier journal
jean claude renault dès 6h30 télématin
françoise laborde recevra jean-marie le
pen aux 4 vérités
on se quitte avec ses images de bébés
élan une nouvelle version de bambi
version nordique
ce sont des nouveau-nés orphelins et du
coup ils ont été adoptés par les
habitants de ce village de norvège à
dimanche pour la soirée spéciale désisté
non